[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
today's video I'm going to be doing some
ranking based on the performance of
previous ranking Style videos you guys
at least most of you seem to enjoy them
so here's another at this stage I've
ranked a lot of different types of
characters I've ranked the most powerful
Slytherin gryffindors hufflepuffs
ravenclaws auras Death Eaters
Dumbledore's Army members Order of the
Phoenix members and more but what I
haven't done yet is rank the most
powerful pure blood Wizards in The
Wizarding World blood status is one of
the most controversial aspects of The
Wizarding World a concept in which
Wizarding families can be distinguished
by the level of magically endowed family
members generally speaking people are
slotted into one of the following
categories pure blood half blood or
muggle we're introduced to quite a few
characters in the Harry Potter story
that come from these pure bloodlines and
they certainly aren't afraid to remind
us of it Malo however what we must
remember is that at the end of the day
pure blood status doesn't mean anything
the most powerful pure Bloods are not
the most powerful Wizards in fact a top
10 list for the most powerful Wizards
would only include a couple of the
people in this list the majority of
powerful witches and wizards in The
Wizarding World are actually half Bloods
before we get started I want to mention
a couple of things first of all I'm
going to omit the Hogwarts Founders and
the Pils as they're sort of op second of
all I'm going to try my best to only
include one person from each visiting
family as otherwise the list could get
quite overcrowded with one surname
thirdly I want you to pause the video
and comment your top 10 list down below
before you dive in anyway without
further Ado here is my top 10 list of
the most powerful pure blood Wizards in
The Wizarding World if I miss or forget
a name that is deserving of a spot
please forgive me number 10 Bill Weasley
Bill Weasley was the eldest Weasley
child born as early as 1970 he attended
Hogwarts between 1982 and 1989 and
during this time he became both a
prefect and Head Boy Bill is considered
by many to be the most powerful of the
Weasley children largely due to his
occupation as a curse breaker one who
removes counters or breaks curses placed
on objects the profession is thought to
be extremely challenging and
particularly dangerous requiring a
complex understanding of magic and a
proven ability to perform a broad
spectrum of different spells bill was
highly skilled in arithmancy jeweling
Transfiguration conjuration charms spell
creation divination and even the dark
arts bill was truly a powerful wizard
before you say hey mly was the strongest
weasy watch the video a little longer
nine Frank Longbottom Frank Longbottom
doesn't make it into the story much and
that's because he's tragically
incapacitated during the first Wizarding
War you see Frank and his wife Alice
Longbottom the parent of Neville
Longbottom were both powerful auras that
joined the Order of the Phoenix and
opposed Lord Voldemort unfortunately for
them however they were a little too good
at their jobs defying him on three
occasions as well as capturing and
imprisoning many of Voldemort's Death
Eaters because of this they were honed
in on and targeted one day Frank and
Alice were attacked with the cruciatus
curse by Bellatrix B Crouch Jr and
rodolphus the strange though the pair
didn't die they were unable to continue
normal life and effectively went insane
Frank being targeted tells me that he
was a very valuable asset for the order
and likely a very powerful wizard who
deserves a spot on this list eight James
Potter James Potter was a British pure
blood wizard born March 27th 1960 to
parents femont and euphemia Potter like
the other Marauders James was so skilled
in the subject of transfiguration that
he was able to become an animus at the
staggeringly young age of 15 after
successfully achieving achieving this
notable accomplishment he was able to
transform into a stag whenever he wanted
in order to accomplish such a feat it
was also necessary that James have
sufficient knowledge of potion making as
becoming an animus for the first time
requires an animus potion a highly
complicated potion that requires
exceptional potion making ability in
addition to Transfiguration and potion
making James was also a talented
jewelist having defeated Snape on
numerous occasions and an accomplished
practitioner of charms having helped to
create the Marauders map alongside the
other members of the group seven Sirius
Black Sirius Black The Godfather of
Harry Potter and member of the black
family began studying at Hogwarts in the
year 1971 along with the other Marauders
during his time at school he was a
talented the rebellious young man with a
knack for performing magic while
sirius's magical development was
somewhat stunted by the extensive amount
of time that he spent in aaban he still
ended up being a supremely powerful
wizard in addition to being highly
skilled at Transfiguration and
eventually becoming an animus assuming
the form of a black dog Sirus was also
skilled at jeweling brewing potions
producing charms producing non-verbal
magic and even oceny six Molly puit
Weasley next up we have Molly puit or as
most of you know her Molly Weasley
that's right Molly hailed from the
powerful pure blood visiting family the
prits the pruit family produced many
powerful witches and wizards including
Molly's Brothers Gideon and Fabi
who died in the first witing war while
fighting off five Death Eaters Molly's
other most significant achievement was
besting powerful witch Bellatrix the
strange one of the most powerful witches
in the entire Wizarding World and one of
Lord Voldemort's most loyal followers
she was primarily portrayed as an
unassuming motherly figure known for her
caring and nurturing manner however
during the Battle of Hogwart Molly
proved that in times of adversity she's
able to tap into levels of power that
will give even the most powerful witches
and wizard s a run for their money she
was skilled in jeweling charms healing
magic potions Transfiguration and even
the dark arts five Horus Lorn Professor
Horus Lorn was a British wizard that
worked at Hogwart School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry he was a highly respected
and accomplished man who served as both
potions master and head of sutherin
house he was a brilliant man and perhaps
one of the most talented potioneer of
his time slug horn was a triple threat
he was cunning wise and bookmart which
made him an exceptionally powerful man
in fact when the death heaters were
returning they tried time and time again
to recruit sarorn who was rather modest
about his own capabilities what would
the death heaters want with a poor
broken down old buffer like me I
imagined they would want to turn your
considerable talents to coercion torture
and murder as well as being a master
potioneer slor was also a very talented
jewelist Transfiguration expert olan's
charms expert dark arts practitioner and
as it turns out EXP expert piano player
four Kingsley shacklebolt Kingsley
shacklebolt was a British pure blood
wizard Order of the Phoenix member
powerful Ora and later Minister for
magic in his youth shacklebolt attended
Hogwarts and performed particularly well
on his NES fulfilling all of the
necessary qualifications to become an
aura before eventually becoming Minister
for magic Kingsley was a high-ranking
aura displayed a very powerful and
balanced arsenal of magical capabilities
Jackal bal's fellow order members held
him in a very high regard
and even Lord Voldemort himself
considered King zy to be a powerful
wizard if that isn't an indicator of his
level of power then I don't know what is
three Alistar Moody considered by many
to be the most famous Aura of all time
alist Moody was a very impressive wizard
Moody joined the order during the first
Wizarding war and is said to be
personally responsible for a very large
portion of the witches and wizards in
aaban this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
Community Moody was a truly impressive
dark wizard catcher and Warrior he would
do whatever it took to win and Moody
served with great distinction during the
first Wizarding War even losing an eye
leg and nose in battles against the
Death Eaters Moody was incredibly brave
but also extremely powerful particularly
in his prime he was a master of dark
arts defense against the dark arts
jeweling charms Transfiguration potions
hology Apparition flying non-verbal
magic and even emancy two Barty Crouch
Jr Barty Crouch Jr was a British pure
blood Wizard and the son of Ministry of
magic official bimus Crouch senior
Crouch Jr has a rich history with the
death heaters and joined them in his
teenage years B Crouch Jr famously
kidnaps and imprisons the powerful Madi
Moody then teaches at Hogwarts School
for an entire year in his stead what's
so impressive about this is that he was
completely undetected even by the
powerful Dumbledore Crouch was powerful
in every area of Magic and was known to
be skilled at jeweling potions charms
Transfiguration oceny non bbal magic and
more but what made Crouch truly
dangerous was his intelligence achieving
12 owls during his time at Hogwarts I
think that Crouch may be one of the most
underrated Wizards in all of history
number one Bellatrix black L strange
Bellatrix L strange born Bellatrix black
from the house of black was a
frightening pure blood witch that came
from a long line of powerful witches and
wizards with a twisted agenda Bellatrix
is undeniably one of the most powerful
people in The Wizarding World basically
only comes after Dumbledore Voldemort
grindlewald and maybe Snape when it
comes to raw power Bellatrix was a known
proponent of the cruciatus curse and had
considerable knowledge in the realm of
the dark arts she was also an expert
jewelist charms expert powerful oans and
tenacious Warrior yes Bellatrix was
defeated by Molly Weasley but I think
it's safe to say that she just let her
ego get the better of her if she hadn't
underestimated Molly she may still be
around today and that concludes this
list had did my top 10 matchup against
yours did I mess up and miss any obvious
ones that deserved a spot comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
[Music]
live